okay good evening everybody uh members
of this committee are the members
officers of the council we have a
visitor from the Press with us this
evening you're very welcome and we also
have members of the public with us as
well she's hiding but I know she's there
so everyone is very welcome to this
meeting of the overview and scrutiny
panel it's the 25th of October 2022. if
the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices down the stairs to
the main uh staircase opposite the list
in the foia assembling Hawley Square on
the green officers will assist us and
advise when it's deemed safe to return
to the chamber
would everyone please make sure their
mobile phones are turned to silent
they're not used to make or receive
phone calls and messages and things
while the meeting is in progress
do note that the meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public so I
want to welcome any members of the
public to the meeting if you're joining
us through the live stream facility the
meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the Internet
is there anyone who's here this evening
who intends to film the meeting
now I can't see anyone so we will move
on then to
um speaking under rule 20.1 I haven't
had any requests for anyone to speak
under rule 20.1
and similarly I haven't had any requests
from members of the public
to speak either so I don't think there
are any who would like to speak
moving on then to the agenda proper
apologies for absence I have apologies
from councilor Huxley I think apart from
councilor
Council Elise okay thank you very much
so he's keeping away for our benefit
good for him good for him
I generated number two then Declarations
of Interest are there any Declarations
of interest that members would like to
make
nope and then we move then to the
minutes of the overview and scrutiny
panel meeting we held on the 30th of
August in 2022 and there has been a copy
attached within the agenda pack for us
to see I hope members have been able to
look at it can I have a proposal that we
accept the minutes if there are no
comments councilor more thank you very
much and a second to please councilor
fellows thank you very much do members
agree thank you very much
foreign
to agenda item number four
um our scheduled Cabinet member
presentation this evening is by the
deputy leader it concerns leving up
funds and regeneration projects in
thanet I'm very pleased to welcome
councilor Pugh and also Louise Askew
who's with us this evening to make the
presentation Council appew thank you
very much
thank you chair and thank you for having
me and uh hello good evening to my
fellow councilors
um we've just got a very short
presentation that I'm going to go
through uh this evening and then of
course very happy to answer any
questions that members may have
um about all all things to do with
leveling up in thanet
um
first up
um I'd like to explain if we just skip
through the presentation
there we go apologies
um you know leveling up and dance
regeneration funds so since the end of
2019 we have bid for and been awarded
over 51 million pounds of government
funding this includes the Ramsgate
future High Street fund which is 2.7
million uh 22.2 million pounds through
the Margate Town deal
Ram's got 11 out fund of a
19.840 million pounds and of course the
Margate 11 out fund of just over 6.3
billion pounds
um there are two other areas with future
High Street funding in Kent Dover and
Medway
um there are also two leveling out fund
programs both in Ashwood and Medway and
Margate is the only Town deal in Kent
um we're one of only two only we're one
of only one of the only places in the
Southeast that's been awarded all of
these programs so I think that's a
massive pass on the back for our
regeneration team and the officers at
the council for all of their hard work
because it's been absolutely fantastic
for us to secure all of this funding
of course each process forbidding for
the funding submitting applications and
the approvals process were different and
I think that adds to the added Dynamic
of all of the work that officers have
done and of course the bidding process
for each required a significant amount
of resources from the council which is
no small task particularly
um in the light of the difficulties that
all councils are experienced at the
moment of course the reporting is also
different for each of the programs we
have recruited a project and program
Administration officer to support the
Regeneration team in responding to the
reporting process to central government
as that is taking up quite a lot of
opposite time and of course the focus of
this presentation is the Margate Town
deal and the Ramsgate level nut fund
moving on to the government's governance
arrangements for these two programs they
are slightly different so I will try not
to board members
um too much but I just want to quickly
whiz through that so the guidance for
the Margate Town deal was that the
council was required to put together a
town Deal Board to oversee the
development of the Town investment plan
and the council then LED on the
development of green book complaint
compliant business cases
which have now been submitted to central
government we've now moved on to the
delivery phase of these projects with
the town dual board having an oversight
role currently the Margaret Town Deal
Board is there to review the risks
ensure good governance arrangements and
being followed in relay are being
followed in relation to delivery of the
projects
um of course as myself as the cabinet
member for economic development I sit on
the town Deal Board alongside the chief
executive
um and the other board members they're a
combination of
um our MP for North Bennett so Roger
Gale we've also got representative from
KCC County councilor there and also
offices from KCC and other people key
people within the wider Margaret
Community we're on that board as well so
it's incredibly inclusive
um moving on to the lemon up fund
um we've set up two leveling up fund
scrutiny panels one for Margate and one
for Ramsgate
um I think it's important to note and I
think members will may remember this
from past four Council meetings from
last year
um that there's no formal requirement
from central government to have a
governance panel
um however we felt that it was important
to add this structure particularly to
ensure that there was that kind of
scrutiny and oversight to do with the
leveling up funds and as they are not
only for such a significant amount of
funding but also there's quite a variety
within particularly the Ramsgate
leveling up fund that we felt it was
important that we had that kind of extra
oversight
um
apologies lost my place
um
as I may not have stated um as a Cabinet
member for economic development I sit on
the panel
um alongside the leader the chief
executive and the relevant MP so for
Margate that's sir Roger Gale and for
Rams game that's Craig McKinley
um the Ramsgate panel also includes a
member from Ramsgate Town Council and
the market panel includes the chief
executive of East Kent College group
namely because of course Margate digital
focuses on delivering that through the
leveling up fund for Margate
uh now uh the market Town deal was one
of the first places uh we were one of
the first places to submit a completed
business case to central government
um which unfortunately was quickly
approved
the creative Land Trust has been
established and has successfully been
approved as a charity
um through an open recruitment process a
set of Trustees have been engaged and an
interim director has been recruited to
deal with the operational setup of the
organization
this will put the charity in a position
to be able to deliver the town deal
funds and I think this is an incredibly
exciting aspect of the Margate Town deal
um although I can't be biased I think
all of the projects are exciting but um
you know particularly to have this
facility within the town deal this
creative land trust trying to kind of
fill that Gap and the difficulties that
people from the creative Industries
which is a very Broad
broad-based abroad industry and the
difficulties that they have in securing
space not just in the town center but in
the wider market area I think that you
know the creative Land Trust as a
charity it enables to be able to fill
that Gap so it's really exciting
um
as a part of this the Council of
commissioned an external legal team to
develop a grant agreement in order that
the council can fund the external
organization to deliver the town deal
project
the grant agreement includes the
specific deliverables from the funding
program that are required from the
council as the accountable body and
approvals through cabinet have been made
to provide the grant to the Margate
creative Land Trust once the grant has
been signed the business case has been
approved from the air has also been
approved for the theater Royal project
and cabinet approvals to start the
Urgent works on the building are in
place
a post will shortly be advertised for a
project manager to help with dungeon
bids to organizations like the national
lottery fund and to continue the
stakeholder engagement from the
development of the business case
we've also got the Winter Gardens
business case that has been approved
officers have started the process to
commission surveys drawings of the sites
and they're developing the brief for the
nighttime economy strategy
and we're also waiting for confirmation
from uh apologies the department for
leveling up uh housing and communities I
believe it's now called
um for approval of the remaining
business cases these are expected
shortly and we're we were slightly
delayed due to some of the challenges in
setting out some of the evaluation
requirements
the monitoring and evaluation for the
town deals every six months it's a
central government reporting on funding
spent match funding jobs created and or
safeguarded projects completed on time
and with bud and within budget
and there are also questions on manual
basis about Economic Development and
regeneration teams and budgets and of
course each project has their own
specific indicators to report on
um and I think that's quite important to
know as well particularly with the
Margate Town dual board is that although
we report central government every six
months the town deal boards you know up
until recently has been meeting on a
monthly basis I think now that projects
and business cases have been signed off
and now that we've made progress with
creative land trust that is now starting
to be a little less infrequent but that
doesn't mean that there's any less
oversight particularly to do with the
business cases and with the projects it
just means that we're now starting to
kind of gather pace and and things are
starting to be released and which is
great because it hopefully means that we
can start seeing some real process
progress
so moving on to the level up fund for
Ramsgate for an initial commission a
number of projects have been developed
to outline stage this has included the
stakeholder engagement in the
development of plans for the site
through this engagement we have more
information about the size requirements
for the fishing facility including the
specific requirements for the
fisherman's Association
a draft feasibility study a feasibility
study has been commissioned for the
smack Boys restaurant and event space
with rooms and engagement has taken
place with a private sector to inform
this work
officers have been out to engage a
multi-disciplinary team to act as
project managers to take the produce up
projects up to River stage three and
contracts have been awarded and
announcements on the team will be made
next week this will help to drive
forward the leveling up fund projects
and they'll be developing an updated
plan for the program and commissioning
surveys designs as appropriate and
helping the team continue with delivery
of these projects and I think it's quite
important just
as I kind of sum up to note that
particularly with the level of funding
that we've received in total well over
51 million pounds recently for
regeneration projects you know that's a
huge achievement not just for this
Council but for our officers who are
working incredibly hard
um and there's funding that the council
is applying for all the time as soon as
soon as it becomes available or we're
notified of it we try our best
um there have been instances where we
haven't been successful we put in an
expression of Interest over the summer
for Arts Council England funding
um
for quite a significant amount of money
and unfortunately we weren't successful
but considering uh the list there that
was shown on the earlier slide of all of
the Regeneration funding that we've
secured recently I think that you know
it's still a resounding success for this
Council and and I think it shows how
hard everyone has been working
um to try and further these aims across
the district
so thank you
thank you very much Council appear very
interesting
um members just uh so that we're not all
trying to commit all these details to
memory
um the uh
link slides will be provided with the
minutes when they come out after this
meeting and thank you very much for
presenting it in the way you have
um do you have any questions that folks
would like to ask okay I'll start at the
back there please with councilor Boyd
and then moving left councilor Keane
thank you chair um you mentioned that
movie was one of the first to submit the
business plans and obviously this
funding's been earmarked for us for a
number of years now it's been a long
process with the current clan in terms
of the cost of things going up
infinite has there been any stretch
zones within those budget plannings and
I think there's been instances before
where we've had a budget all of a sudden
it's now over budget and we can't
deliver it so has there been any stretch
zones put in place for all of these
projects because some of them could be
at risk
sorry Chad I was waiting for you to say
that I could speak um so that we don't
kind of on off on off if it's a question
directed to you uh Council poo perhaps
you could just answer as soon that is
that is absolutely fine don't worry
um thank you councilor both your
question
um I will refer to Louise but I think
actually we had a question on this uh
quite a few months ago at cabinet uh to
do with part of the rounds get 11 out
fund and and future High Street fund and
I think it's factored into the budgets
um but I will refer defer to Louise so
obviously each of those projects will
have an element of contingency but
um we've had a number of conversations
with central government
um since prices started to increase and
access to labor and materials started to
become harder
um and they're very aware of the impact
that it's having I mean we're as the
presentation said we're one of
um very few places that have got this
many schemes but there's 101 Town Deal
programs I think there's 75 future High
Street fund I'm not sure how many
leveling up there are but it's a
significant issue for all of those
places so there is an element of value
engineering so all of our projects
can still happen but they might be to a
lesser degree
and or it's more reliant on getting
other funding from elsewhere like
National Lottery Heritage fund or Arts
Council or you know the private sector
so none of our projects are kind of make
or break on the basis of the funding
that's been allocated and there's there
is an element to Value engineer that and
it's one of the things that we report
back to central government within our
risk register
and I think apologies Jeff I could just
come back I think just to add to what
Louise said councilor Boyd there's and I
apologies I neglected to mention it
within my presentation but you know a
lot of
funding not just the Margate Town deal
but a lot of the leveling up funds as
well is that you know the intention of
it or my understanding of the intention
intention from central government is
that this is effectively seed funding so
this isn't just about throwing some
public money our way and clients saying
best of luck you know that's it this is
about you know giving the local area
that boost that it needs you know and I
liken it to what the turn of
contemporary has done for Margate in the
old town of the art scene is that it's
it's creating that kind of seed
investment and giving that boost to the
area in the way that it can hope in the
hopefully it can encourage private
investment to come in and you know and
that would be you know five or six times
or maybe even tenfold what the initial
central government funding has been so
you know I think there's a room within
that and with the private sector to kind
of potentially fill in some of those
gaps if they do appear
thank you cancel the key
thank you
um I mean it's really great to have this
investment in thanet so I'm really
pleased about that I'm also very pleased
to hear about the extra staff because I
know the team worked very hard and I'm
not sure how you'd have managed if there
weren't extra people coming on to help
with the process my question really is
about the engagement with the public
obviously I know we've got a couple of
members of the public on the town Deal
Board but I understand one of them for
whatever reasons hasn't been able to go
to many meetings and I just think is
this a missed opportunity for public
representation if someone isn't able to
come along to regular meeting should we
look at that but also the the people's
panel I understand it's not a
decision-making
board so it's about public opinion
but again it's sort of
you know how how effective is that that
because we don't seem to hear much about
that so
um is is that doing the job that we want
it to do
thank you
thank you councilor I will defer to
Louise in a second because it's probably
more interesting what she's got to say
in response to your questions than mine
um I think the people's panel is
incredibly important I think it has an
important role particularly with the
market Town deal
um I think it's always hard particularly
when you form a board particularly for
the as we have for the market Town deal
of trying to kind of be inclusive and
encapsulate and incorporate everyone so
I do take that at that point on board
um if there are board members that are
struggling to attend then you know
that's something that we can look into
and of course it's important that you
know board members are able to to give
their time and attend as regularly as
they can almost all the time because
it's important they're there to review
the decisions that are made and that
they understand what's going on
um I think that's incredibly important I
think also as well from an engagement
perspective you know it's certainly
important that we engage with the whole
Community with all residents in done it
as well but I think as I've mentioned
before my impression has been
um
from the feedback that we've received
when we've engaged with residents is
that there's developing a certain apathy
when it comes to engagement because
there's only so many times that actually
somebody can stand in the High Street of
a clipboard and interrupt people on a
Tuesday and ask them what they think
needs to be improved in the High Street
because you know effectively you know
there's okay it's great for us to engage
and kind of poll residents and ask what
they want to see but you know if you're
having to give the same answers over and
over again and nothing's really changing
then it kind of defeats the object of
that
um but that's just my impression for me
it doesn't mean that we should stop
asking residents for their views um but
I'll now defer to uh to Louise
um
terms of the people
a lot with the panel as a representative
group in the development of the Town
investment plan to to check that Margate
feel for it and make sure that it was
relevant and then in the development of
the business cases we referred back to
the people's panel and as you rightly
said they're not a decision-making body
but it was about testing what the board
was thinking what the engagement was
showing us broader engagement and what
the evidence was showing us and we
paused that after we submitted the final
business case and we've had a bit we've
you know there's been a bit of a way in
terms of turning those around and the
chair is now doing a bit of a review and
we'll probably
um contact the people's panel and find
out their view in in the panel existing
what we don't want to do is
um have a you know take up people's
valuable time when there isn't anything
necessarily to engage on it was really
important in the developer development
of the Town investment plan and actually
central government require quite
complementary on the engagement activity
we did do in the build up to developing
the investment the town investment plan
and the business cases because lots of
areas didn't do quite as much as as we
had it was a tricky time it was um
through some of our kind of covered
lockdowns so that did provide some
challenge for that
um on the governance slide I also put
there's also a comment around
um reviewing governance structures for
each of the
um programs we are a Pathfinder area for
central government there's 10 or 11 of
them across the country they've got a
number of programs and what we're trying
to work with them is streamlining some
of it because as councilor Pugh said we
have to report differently quarterly six
monthly we have different indicators we
have different forms it's a different
timing I mean it just it adds more than
it needs to so we are having some
discussions around that and the chair of
the Margate Town Deal Board is
considering the terms of reference as
well now we're moving into delivery
having moved out of kind of project
development and strategy development and
so that's where we're up to now what we
don't want to do as councilor P said is
just engage for engaging sake we want to
do it meaningfully so that people can
see what we're asking them and what the
outcome is and and the challenge with
the time scales for all of these you
know we were announcing being awarded
money 18 months ago and we're still in
that kind of development phase but
that's because of the time scales with
central government and the you know the
things that we have to do to be able to
um
unlock the funding
councilor Tomlinson please
uh thank you chair I'd be wrong for me
not to say something on this subject
um
thank you Council Pugh and uh all
involved I mean I've been following this
sort of like many of us from day one and
I fully appreciate that things don't
happen overnight and it has to be done
correctly
um
the things that concern me and it's
picked up by other people
um those have been around for a while
and I always saying I'm getting old I
know things are different now with this
funding coming in
um but we've seen here before where
money has been shall we say thrown at
the area
um
and we don't see anything for it now I'm
not going to bore you with what those
things are because they're in the past
we're looking at the future uh
we're hearing of sort of projects
I think Joe public out there
would like to know what those projects
really are
um I know you've stated and I obviously
look at the cabinet reports and so on
it's been agreed through cabinet and all
the other bits and pieces you have to go
through totally understand it's got to
be squeaky clean
but we've got this situation where and
people are I'm saying as it is I'm sure
you know this
when they use stronger words that I'm
going to but when are we going to see
something
and an example if I may um and it's not
for me because I can't do it but the
skate park in cliftonville
the whole thing looks good sorry oh well
I can do anything you know that
um the whole thing looks a mess it has
done for years I do know the background
of it all like many of us in this
Authority do
but I understand that's got all the
go-ahead the funding
the lot
planned permission the lot nothing's
happened
these are the things which the people
out there the public and I know I'm
talking Margate our friends from
Ramsgate here
um I'm sure they're feeling the same
we're all so excited what's going to
happen
and I've always said it and I will say
it until I finish that until I see that
first brick laid
I don't believe it's gonna happen
and all that skateboard skateboarded
well you never know you might see me the
world champion one day but uh I doubt it
but
I have you know I say I'm certainly not
having to go at the team because I know
exactly what has to well near on what
has to go on
um then I'm not knocking anybody there
because I don't do that but um Joe
public out there want to see the bricks
starting to be laid
um otherwise it's going to come back and
bite us
thank you thank you councilor Tomlinson
um and if members will look back up at
the presentation Louise has just gone
back to the Margate Town Deal Board and
I think you're completely right Castle
Thompson I appreciate uh the residents
can be frustrated because there's a lot
of information there's a lot to this and
I appreciate that I probably uh whiz
through this board
um a bit no no no but a bit quickly
earlier but um you know
effectively with the different phases
and different projects within the
Margate Town deal I think that this is
is different from what we've seen before
with Public Funding in the you know as
you've just said about the skate park
you know when these things are completed
or if they're not
there's something tangible and there's
something clear that residents can see
um has been delivered or not depending
on on the case
um you know when you're right you're
right about uh using the skate park as
an example things have progressed things
are progressing but I think as Louise
alluded to earlier you know this we
found out we secured the funding you
know 18 months ago um you know there's a
lot of kind of things that need to be
done particularly with the business
cases and getting things signed off and
you know I'm probably the most active
Cabinet member at cabinet because
there's constantly something to do with
the town deal or the leveling up funds
that you know is being brought to
cabinet for consideration
um because of course you know these
aren't small amounts of money and and
there's constantly things that we as a
council as the accountable body and
there's a really responsible for trying
to deliver all of this effectively
um there's a lot that we have to kind of
divert and sign off and and go through
the motions with
um
so I completely appreciate that but I
think that particularly with the Margate
Town deal and the 11 up funds I think
that these are different from what we've
seen before I think that you know there
is tangible uh something tangible
something real that residents will be
able to see
um similar to how councilor Boyd raised
the issue with particularly with the
rising costs of materials and stuff like
that you know things like that have been
factored in and you know I'm sure
central government are aware of that you
know they want this gun money to be
spent they want it to be actually
utilized you know there's no point uh
the department giving out this money to
local councils and local authorities and
then it just being sent back you know
that's a bit pointless
um you know and I think that's really
important but there are things that that
are a foot you know when you
particularly look at you know the oval
Bandstand and The Lawns up in
cliftonville and the work that's gone in
there one of the first things that I did
as a Cabinet member was sign off the
asset transfer for the for the oval band
stands and stuff like that so you know
there are things that are constantly
happening and things are constantly
moving along I just think that you know
really
particularly over the last couple of
years we have been bogged down with
trying to sort out a lot of the
processes and this is where hopefully
you know we're now going to start seeing
some of that tangible change because I
completely agree you know it was only
um I think it was earlier today I shared
an email from them from the charter
Trustees for Margate
um with some concerns that a visitor had
shared with the Charles trustees with
their experience of coming to Margate
you know there's more work that needs to
be done clearly you know I don't think
that just because this is underway that
you know we can tick that box and you
know ignore any negative comments you
know there's still a lot of work that
needs to be done you know in all of the
towns you know in the High Street in
Margate you know and particularly in
Ramsgate and everything so you know
I do take your point but I think you'll
see that this will really start to turn
things around
I do have a trowel if and I'm free on
Saturday morning if you need help with
the first brick chair though that would
be great that'd be great
antenna fellows
thank you Joe
um firstly
um we expect at least Council Peter said
um stunning figure 51 million I think
Louise in a regen department needs to be
congratulated and I don't think we
celebrate that enough with the residents
I think we only hear negative stuff
surrounding Dreamland Etc so I just want
to ask a few questions um the creative
Land Trust
um got six million for refurbishing
buildings have they identified the
buildings that are going to refurbish
can you share that
yeah thank you Castle fellows so I
actually met with the chair of the
creative Land Trust last week
um
and we were actually discussing uh this
at the moment and and they're formally I
think as I outlined earlier when I spoke
they're formally in the process of the
board has been set up they've gone into
inter entering director in for the next
six to nine months and they're now
starting to kind of you know go through
that process
um you know something interesting that
the chair told me last week was that
their last board meeting I think went on
for I think four or five hours you know
seven hours that we said
um you know which of course isn't
exactly in one sitting might I add in
one day
um so there's of course there's a lot of
stuff they've got to go through and and
that's what the chair was telling me
about is that they're currently trying
to identify uh spaces and sites within
within Margate
um so that they can move this forward
you know because there's also a lot of
things that particularly for a charity
that you wouldn't consider necessarily
from the get-go are important but they
incredibly are so you know they're
starting to make that progress and it's
something that we as a council and I've
reiterated this to the chair and the
whole of the board of the CRT is that we
as a council we're very happy to support
them and facilitate any way that we can
help with introductions and stuff like
that but as I'm sure you can appreciate
you know the property Market
particularly around here is moving
incredibly quickly not just residential
but commercial as well so you know it's
why I think we were all very keen and
particularly at the regen team and
myself to ensure that the CLT could be
set up as quickly as possible so that it
can hit the ground running and really
start to to make some progress but short
answer to your question is that yes they
are looking at sites at the moment so
we're hoping that they're going to be
securing some soon and they can move
things forward
so can I put a suggestion forward maybe
uh the Arlington Square could make a
good creative quarter I think it's all
empty and needs some work and I can
bookend Margate as well the Old Town one
end and the creative islands and quarter
the other end I don't know if that's
been suggested
uh Council fellows that's a fantastic
idea um and that's certainly something
that I'll share with creative Land Trust
if they haven't been looking into that
already so yeah but it's exactly those
type of sites that you know creative
Land Trust will be looking at
um and and I think that's what kind of
forms the wider generation regeneration
of the area isn't it really uh
particularly Parts like that so yeah
okay secondly um Dreamland for four
million and they've got a plan when
they're going to start when that's going
to happen is 4 million enough if it's
not have they got the money to finish
the project
Etc
so thank you Council fellow so 4 million
isn't for the the total cost of the
refurbishment of the cinema building and
and what I believe used to be kind of
the Sun Cafe
um at the top
um it forms part of the overall cost but
it's not a complete the complete cost
for the refurbishment
um
that I think has always been the
intention with part of this being
included within the market Town deal as
I referenced earlier to do you know with
all the market Town doing the 11 and up
you know a lot of this is is is
effectively seed funding
um to kind of help kick-start things and
then you know secure private more
private funding uh to help things uh go
along the way as well so that's my
understanding um but I will defer to
Louise because she may have more
information to share
yeah so in terms of
um information about the projects the
website's a really good place
um every time we get kind of new news or
we're developing parts of the project we
try and update
um on the Margate Town deal pages and
the Ramsgate and the leveling up on
pages Project Specific information and
we're working with dreamlands at the
moment to put some narrative around what
their project actually is we've got it
in a business case but that's quite a
cold
um document so just to articulate some
of what the Project's going to look like
and what the time scales are but um
equally it was about bringing in that
much funding so they have allocated four
million pounds match against the four
million so it's the only one of the Town
deal projects that's bringing in
significant private investment as it
currently stands we suspect the creative
Land Trust as it moves along will bring
in some private investment from
operators and and those creative
businesses my front Dreamland has the
significant amount of match funding
thanks and lastly um
on the Ramsgate one the refurbishment of
the rovo but that we're still hopeful
for
a ferry operator are we still fingers
crossed for that
can you cancel the fellows um
I think that we should be hopeful yeah I
think it's the policy of this council is
our policy to see an operational Port
um you know I think that's incredibly
important
um let's see what happens and hopefully
with the level of that fund I think as
I've said before that will kind of kick
start things really
um so yeah
foreign
T in here for a second and forgive my
ignorance please but that uh issue of
the uh
it's gone
the railroad
oh that's on the next slide don't worry
there it is the the please forgive my
ignorance because the birth is capable
of holding a row row Ferry
that doesn't mean that's all it can do
does it
does it does it mean other vessels can
use that
birth yes it does chair yes so it
doesn't necessarily restrict it just to
uh railroad fairies at the moment that's
an aspiration but the physical structure
could be used for other things yes yes
that's my understanding thank you for
that clarity thank you
thank you chair and thanks for your
presentation councilor Pugh and
congratulations to the team brilliant
work and uh share councilor Keane's
relief that you're getting more staff
and and so you're not going to hopefully
Buckle Under The Strain
um I wanted to pick up on some of the
things that other councilors have asked
about the sharing of information you're
talking about the information that's on
the website Louise which is which is
helpful in the updating of that I'm
hoping that now we've got some more
detailed business cases those can be
shared with members
because it would be really interesting
to have a bit more detail there and then
I wanted to talk about sharing
information with members of the public
as well so sorry yeah apologies I just
wanted to come back and respond to that
and say that if we can share all of that
with members I'm more than happy for us
to do that I mean I'll confer with uh
the region team but I see no reason why
I can't see him
well we may not come across them but
there may be a you know something yeah
there may be some time that's what I
mean is that you know I can't as a
Cabinet member I can't Envision that
being a problem
um I'm more than happy for that and and
for information in general it may be
that actually that's something that if
we can make public apologies if we can
make public
um all of that information so that
members of the public can can look at
that and review that then that's
something that I'm very supportive of as
well but let's take that away and let's
see if that's something that we can do I
just wanted to pick up on the business
about the public because of um of
council Thomason raised it about people
wanting to see things happening but I
think if people can't see something
happening to have the information about
what the time scale is what the process
is what the steps are towards that kind
of thing and we had a great presentation
yesterday at the briefing from mavia
about the thanic voice project and and
about the key thing that residents had
said in surveys being about they want to
see us being more transparent so I think
picking up on the good news point if we
can share this is happening here's an
exciting thing that's that's developing
etc etc inaccessible ways that members
of the public can see and understand
then even even if they don't see uh uh
Council Piper with his travel laying the
first brick they can see that there's a
prospect of that happening by xdate Etc
that kind of information I think is
going to be really valuable and will
help us take the public with us and we
need that
thank you
councilor Wing please thank you chair
and I I think it's a testament to the
hard work of our TDC staff that they've
managed to get hold of such a
significant amount of money to to spend
across the whole of the aisle I'm
convinced that there's more more out
there and that we should be exploring
other opportunities and also supporting
the community to apply for bids as well
where we've got the expertise I've got a
number of questions to ask so I'm going
to do them one at a time because
otherwise I tend to rabble on I I want
to understand the finances so I'm going
to go to the oval Band Stand and a
Dreamland so 500 000 to 1 and 4 million
to the other
is this money allocated to them or is it
virtual money that they can have access
to who oversees this finance and who
oversees the program's progress against
the spending of the finance
thank you Council Wing uh I'll defer to
Louise
intercation of funding
um the Margate Town Deal Board had a
project call out and people could put
forward or organizations groups could
put forward and project proposals and
they were taken through a framework of
kind of scoring against Town deal
um priorities and then the local Margate
Town Deal Board priorities and then the
board did some priority prioritization
of those and some of the projects were
grouped together which is how we got the
four interventions
um so at the time grass bid for or put
forward a proposal for the 500 000 and
Dreamland proposal forward for four
million and that was tested in the town
Deal Board did that kind of testing in
terms of those projects in delivering
the outcomes of um Town deal in terms of
the kind of assurance process around the
funding I mean in each of the cabinet
papers we've brought forward we kind of
outline what that Assurance process is
and the section 151 officer is
responsible for signing that process off
um all of the groups and organizations
that are
um
third-party organizations that are
delivering
um any of the Town deal or leveling up
projects will have a grant agreement and
I think we've articulated through some
cabinet papers we've we brought in some
external lawyers to develop a robust
Grant agreement and then anything over a
million pound
um a million pounds those lawyers then
put together the specifics that relate
to that Grant and that is signed off by
the recipient and and section 151
officer and has all the kind of relevant
things around clawback what they can and
can't do with the funding links to the
monitoring and evaluation requirements
the outputs and outcomes that they put
forward as part of their project and
that went into the town investment plan
or the leveling up fund bid so all of
that is within that Grant agreement so
they don't they won't have any of the
funding until they have that Grant
agreement as part of their proposals
they will have set out their profile for
spend and that's gone up to central
government so we are expecting funding
on the basis of that profile of spend in
some cases that might have slipped and
so
um we will expect some of that to move
on albeit we may already have that
funding in our bank account on in terms
of the monitoring and evaluation all of
the projects are required to
um
advise on spend and they have to
evidence that through invoices so all of
that has to come back to us to be able
to assign prove and sign off and we have
to send that back to central government
so that kind of monitoring evaluation
process picks up all of that
um I think that answers all of that
question so so basically they get given
the money so the oval band stand's been
given yes they're a third party delivery
so that's sat in some bank account that
they have with with rules and
regulations on the governance of that
given this is public money is there any
is there any scope for if a resident
wants to see what's happened to that
government money how how can that be in
the public domain given given that these
people are actually taking a fair whack
of public money would would only be fair
for some of that information on what the
money's been spent on to be in the
public domain at some point
I mean I think we would have all the
project updates to say these are what
the projects have spent on what we
probably need to take back is that
process of what information we share and
how we share it some of that might be
commercially sensitive in terms of
contracts that have been awarded but um
I probably need to take that bit back
we're still somewhere from handing those
funds over for delivery but the other
thing to add to that is they are also
required to follow at least hours or
very similar to our procurement
processes so it is they cannot be
awarding it just to someone that they
know they have to go through due process
in terms of awarding contracts so you
know getting quotes Etc I think it goes
back sorry counseling if I could just
add to that to what Louisa said
um basically got a question I think and
that's one of my main concerns um when I
first became the cabinet member for this
responsibility this was that this is a
lot of a lot of public uh money a lot of
Public Funding
um and that as we distribute that money
you know there's a certain private
sector that does incredibly well
um as consultants and consultancies and
we all think we're all aware as
counselors of the various consultancy
fees that uh third party and private
sector can charge particularly to public
bodies and public organizations and in
my theory of concern was that you know a
lot of this funding
um would get swallowed up by that kind
of consultancy fees you know by
instructing Consultants to kind of run
this and run that and advise on this and
advise on that and that you know very
gradually a lot of the funding would
kind of evaporate and we'd have very
little to show for it um and I think as
Louise as outlined you know part of the
process is in Iden to find that is that
you know across all of this they've got
two evidence a lot of things and I
suppose also as well particularly with
the oval band stand for the market Town
deal or with the skate park and you know
particularly as a council and as
residents we'll we'll know if things are
delivered or not it's not like you can
just pretend that a skate park has been
built when it hasn't and the same with
the improvements for the oval Bandstand
so there's certainly that aspect
um that we're quite lucky to have but uh
yeah I just wanted to add that
I think he goes back to councilor
Tomlinson's where the residents need to
know what's happened to that money and
sometimes it's not always clear and I
don't think they want to know which
companies have benefited they want to
see the outcomes of a project and
turning the page I'm afraid can I just
jump in for a second please counseling
I'd like to bring and for the benefit of
the public who are watching our s151
officer Mr Blondo would like to just
thank you chair just to add to the
points very detailed points at Louise
and Council please have already
um set out
um I think it's the point I really want
to just stress is that the payments of
the two organizations we're talking
around here with grass to do with the
Bandstand and with Dreamland is the
payments I made in the rears so
effectively they've got to deliver those
Works before we pay them so it's not as
if there's slaves of cash that will be
sat in their bank accounts effectively
they will detail that they'll they will
spend that work those undertake those
work spend their money in advance and
then it's recovered through this grant
process and there's a very detailed
monitoring and evaluation form that
Louise has spoken about that that we go
through in order to
um release those monies and also provide
that information back up to central
government as well and in terms of
providing a breakdown of what's spent on
we do we'd have to be careful because as
as uh Council Pugh and Louis said they
are obviously private companies that'll
have their own possible subcontracts in
place our our engagement is with them
and that's our responsibilities to say
what we've spent with them and
ultimately that would be uh disclosed
the same way as we do with any other
third-party all spending over 500 pound
is detailed on our website so if you
want to see anything we spend with any
private sector company it's all there
when our supply spend list
that makes makes me understand it better
I've got some more with some more
questions I'm afraid uh I still don't
see how the roro can actually be part of
the green Port because it's going to
involve ferries that use Diesel and
lorries that that and but you know I can
maybe maybe we'll let that one slide but
the row row I mean the building and they
will come approach really really
concerns me so how far have we
progressed in attracting a a ferry I
don't need to know the ferry company
because that would be commercially
sensitive but I do think the residents
want to know we may have two or three
Ferry companies that are interested
in terms of attracting cargo ferries a
destination Port so obviously if we're
going to be a port we've got to have
somewhere for our ferries to actually go
to so there's no point in in building
our row row that might have a ferry but
there's no there's no Port you know
Cali's I went through Calais is
absolutely fabulous they've clearly
spent some money there so I've after
that I've got one more question but if
you could answer those ones and then
I'll get to my last question
yeah thank you councilor Wing I mean of
course if she could appreciate we can't
necessarily uh name names and companies
and stuff like that but what I can say
is that um discussions are ongoing
particularly with not only operators but
interested parties
um in the future of the port and
delivering the port and a ferry service
for Ramsgate as well so I appreciate
that's incredibly vague and I'm not
trying to be vague
um
that I think you know our priority is
this Administration as a council is that
we want to try and deliver the best not
just for the district but for Ramsgate
as well and you know I personally see uh
you know the result resuming of a ferry
service in Ramsgate has been quite vital
to that really I think as you've just
said about Calais you know that they
wouldn't be able to spend nowhere near
as what they've done in beautifying
Calais it's not like I can't remember it
being that nice but I'll be there in a
couple of months time so I'll I'll have
to take your word for it until then
cancel the wing but you know I think
part of that is that they wouldn't have
been able to to spend as much as they
have and and on the works of beautifying
Calais unless there was a successful uh
you know ferry service going through
Calais um as you're saying about making
it a destination
um I do think that actually a lot of the
Regeneration projects that I've outlined
above and you know I'd harking Back to
the Future High Street fund as well
although it's not the full amount that
we went in for it's only a portion of
that you know that can link into it as
well because it's about you know making
effectively Rams game than a destination
and I think that ties into it and you
know if we want uh people to come here
on on the ferry or you know I know uh
quite a few years ago there was a cruise
ship that came in and I think a chairman
of the council or a former mayor of one
of our town and and parishes had such a
good time with the the captain on there
that he almost got left behind
um he almost almost went back with the
with the cruise ship so you know I think
there's certainly an aspect of of trying
to deliver all of that and I think all
of that links into this really
um so yeah but that's that's my my
comments
I'll remain skeptical I'm I'm afraid but
have you seen any other alternative
businesses on the port come forward with
ideas and match funding so given we are
spending 9 million on the pool if
there's a clamor to use our Port then
really there should we should be
fighting them off and some of those
business should be becoming on board
with match funding and becoming Partners
just like you've just described with
Dreamland which is fabulous so have we
seen any any companies come forward with
wanting to use our pool but I maybe use
the port in a different way or match
Fund in a different in a different style
of a project
yeah thank you thank you councilman I
will uh I would defer to uh Louise in a
second I mean what I wanted to to come
back to you on that is that you know I
think the port as an asset is incredibly
attractive uh to many investors
um you know from around the country and
and abroad I think it provides a great
opportunity
um
there's conversations that are that are
ongoing and there certainly have been
approaches made uh to the council and
conversations that we've had with people
that are interested in in coming to the
port and investing in the port
um I'm very open to conversation so if
there's any that you're aware of that
that maybe we're not more than happy to
kind of link that up as well
um
but I think it's incredibly difficult I
think you know as much as the port may
be seen as this massive huge expanse of
concrete you know I think that
particularly as this level out fund
starts to kind of you know kick start
and and hit the ground running you know
there'll be an incredibly lot of
competition for for space up there um
you know and it's incredibly hard to try
and you know include everyone
um because of course we want to make
sure that there's enough variety down
there but that it's a success really um
but I will I will defer to Louise now
thanks
um I think at the members briefing we
talked about kind of zoning of the port
and we've shared a slide that showed and
the land that was kind of allocated to
the poor infrastructure project and and
then the land that's currently used by
wind farm operators and other businesses
that are already there and then the
space that's now available as a kind of
opportunity site
um with bringing in this external
project manager employers agent team to
help take the projects up to Ruby stage
three that will enable us to add some
more capacity to those discussions and
start to flesh out in a bit more detail
what some of that looks like there will
be those opportunity sites that once
we've identified the exact site for the
green Campus will still be available
we're going to do these bits first and
and deliver the leveling up fund first
and with a with a mind to what they
might look like in the future but
equally we want these things to
um come to fruition and potentially be
oh and be successful useful to then see
how we can make better use of other
parts of the port rather than just
taking those out to the market straight
away we're having lots of conversations
and in terms of people will come forward
with ideas but we do need to deliver the
leveling up fund program within the time
scale set by central government so our
Focus will certainly be on those and we
talked about the narrative that we'd put
together around the port and I think
that's due to go online this week on on
the website and and so the link will be
shared once that's up there and that
articulates a bit more about the kind of
Journey and and
um
uh the um the work we're doing around
the kind of poor infrastructure but this
team coming on board will really help
move some of that stuff forward
um in terms of to towards delivery phase
but it is an open port and I think going
back to um your point chair it is an
open port Ramsgate is open boats can
come in now this infrastructure
investment just enables a broader range
of boats to be able to come in and use
our facilities and the things that we
are looking at is how what are the
different models of operation as well to
sit alongside so it isn't so much a case
that we're going out to find a ferry
operator because it's an open port so
operators can come in and use it and
this infrastructure investment allows
that to happen more easily
afraid chair thank you for that we are
very different to Cali as you'll see
it's a massive port color and we're very
tiny so we we can't really compare the
two I wondered if I could ask about the
knock-on effect to some of the present
uh tenants we have there in particular
the Sea Cadets in the smack boys I'm
really concerned that we have a really
essential
Organization for young people that works
with some of our most vulnerable that
may be left homeless and they need a
home that is quite clearly near the sea
because they're Sea Cadets so I hope
we're not going to dump them in land
somewhere but so far neither they or the
three Ward councilors have been given
any reassurances that they will be found
somewhere suitable around the pool and I
think that although it's a very small
thing it should be a priority for us to
make sure they have a home
thank you councilor Wing I mean I think
the comparison I think it was you that
made the Calais comparison thirst um but
I'm certainly not going to take credit
for that but
uh just uh to try and address and answer
your concerns about uh the smart boys
building and the Sea Cadets and that
kind of stuff
um conversations are ongoing with the
seeking debts and I appreciate how
important it is that we find an
alternative home for them
um you know I appreciate that whilst
they may enjoy using the the smart boys
building it's not particularly well
suited for their needs and I appreciate
that they have been using it
um and of course it's important that
they have a space available and
particularly near the sea
um of course I'm not suggesting that we
put them in land and then they have to
change their name
um
but at the same time you know it's
something that as I said conversations
are ongoing I've actually been invited
um to go and watch them on parade and
just trying to you know I'm just trying
to facilitate uh availability so that I
can I can go and do that but you know
completely take your point on board it's
something that the council that we're
looking into particularly with the
property and the States team on you know
potentially if there's something within
our portfolio that we can offer to them
at one of our assets or if there's a way
that we can help facilitate and find
them in alternative space
um somewhere and something that's more
suitable for their needs and of course
they're they're I suppose a casualty of
of the letter fund that they will have
to move but at the same time there's
that opportunity there in the you know
the smart boys building and everything
will be regenerated and redone and and
and will be even better than it was
before but I will I will defer to Louise
so we do know the type of space and the
size of space that they need so they've
shared that information with us and um
in putting part of the next kind of
phase of work we will consider that in
terms of some of the other projects that
we're delivering in and around
um the port and harbor
um we are also talking to other
organizations to match them up thinking
about some of the work they do around
skills and supporting their young people
because we think that is really
important
um there has been a bit of a vacuum of
activity
um the smack boys project isn't due to
come online until you know instantly so
they they're not being kicked out as it
were tomorrow but bringing in this team
to help add some capacity will mean
actually some of that work will be able
to move on we know the space is not fit
for purpose for their needs and we know
that they are thinking about what that
might look like and how they might
engage with other organizations so um
yeah they're not being turfed out
without us looking at where their home
might be because they do have as you say
a really important role to play within
our community and we totally recognize
that as part of this work
thank you counselor radical please
lovely Ed just a quick question uh thank
you Chris for the sort of clarification
regardless because I think people's
perspective is that with a third party
is there they're getting these large
sums of money and they're you know
they're sort of keeping their own bank
um is there a time scale for the third
parties to claim that fund and obviously
with these sort of economic sort of
don't sort of turned at the moment
obviously they're relying on Match
funding is there a time not on they have
to claim it with a certain period and if
not what will happen to that but will
that go back into other projects
so delivery of the Margate Town deal is
by March 2025 so there is a time limit
around the spending of that funding
albeit there is uh an element of
freedoms and flexibilities that we have
with the process that the funding is
allocated to us
um each of them as I said earlier each
of them all have put a kind of profile
of spend forward in terms of where they
think they will be in on each step and
um we will expect to see things like
planning permissions and and certain
Reba stages to be worked up before
funding is allocated if for example any
of the third party projects came forward
and said actually we can't do this for
whatever reason then we would have to do
a kind of re-profiling process so if it
was the town Deal Board it would go back
to the board
um or if it was leveling up it would
come back into the scrutiny panel and we
would need to do a project adjustment to
central government so that's a kind of
formal process that says okay we've
allocated x amount of money to this
project it can't go forward we would
like to deliver this one and that's on
the basis that it was in the town deal
investment plan or it delivers a similar
thing but in a different building and we
we would have to potentially already
also
um do a new economic case within the
business case process and that goes
through central government for approval
so there is a whole process around
projects that don't come forward
Council Pew thank you very much do you
have any other final words you'd like to
add or are you concluded for this set I
don't know chair thank you very much and
what I would say to to you and to all of
the uh scrutiny panel members is that
you know uh we are as open and
transparent as we possibly can be I
think all members know that that my door
is always open and and if there are any
questions particularly to do with any of
the projects that are associated with
this funding please do let me know um
because it's incredibly important that
we share as much information as possible
um particularly so that we can reassure
the community uh you know if there's a
specific project that they want to hear
about or they're concerned about but I
certainly take on board Council
Tomlinson's point about you know us
trying to make sure that imagine as much
information is out there as possible so
that residents that know that things are
happening and that they are progressing
um and that it's not just that 18 months
ago we secured a lot of this funding and
nothing really has happened and so I I
definitely take it on board so thank you
thank you very much it's been a a very
informative hour and lots of questions
from the from the panel thank you very
much for that uh it just remains for me
then too and if you don't mind for the
benefit of the members of the public uh
to thank councilor Pugh who is our
Deputy leader and Cabinet member for
economic development to thank Louise
Askew our director of regeneration and
for his contributions Chris Blundell
rs151 officer thank you very much for
bringing the briefing to us this evening
if you have an opportunity to leave now
before we move on then please please do
all you're welcome to stay
foreign
[Applause]
then is the housing performance report
for quarter 122-23 and it's a real
pleasure to welcome as always councilor
Jill bayford who's our cabinet member
for housing and also this evening to
welcome Michelle Jackson our resident
involvement manager so welcome to you
both I'll hand over now to you for your
presentation
thank you thank you chair and thank you
for taking the time to scrutinize the
tenant and Lease holder Services
performance report for quarter one I'm
deputizing for our tenant and
leaseholder services manager at Sally
O'Sullivan tonight so I thought I'd give
you some key messages coming from the
report and then take your questions
after an Endeavor to answer as many of
those as I can so
if I could firstly look at the
compliance performance our landlord
compliance performance so we are pleased
to report that we have managed
uh to maintain a full compliance in most
of the areas so the areas included in
that include passenger lifts Legionella
risk assessments asbestos fire risk
assessments and gas safety We are
continuing to tackle the fire assessment
the fire risk assessment actions and the
stats that are within the report don't
tell the full story here so at the end
of quarter one we had a total of 147
actions outstanding
134 of which were overdue
this is down from quarter four where we
had 219.
we completed 118 actions in quarter one
but of course these figures don't add up
and that's because this is a rolling log
of
um actions that are coming out from the
continued work that we do to deliver to
do our fire risk assessments so the more
fire risk assessments we do the more
actions we pick up and therefore
um the list of actions uh accumulate and
decrease as we work through them we are
working really hard in this area to
bring down as many of the outstanding
actions as we can
one of the areas that we are a little
disappointed about in terms of
performance is the domestic electrical
safety
this currently starts at 91.27 and this
is only a one increase
within quarter one and it peels against
the 15 increase that we achieved in 20
in quarter four
um our quarter four performance was
really due because we had extra
contractors on board which we brought in
to achieve the recovery action plan
we had to stand these down at the end of
quarter four due to procurement
legislation and contract standing orders
but we are keeping the pressure on
Mayors at the moment to to carry on with
this work but they simply can't cope
with the amount of work that it is
coming through we are therefore
procuring our own contractor which we
hope to bring on board at the end of
quarter two and Mayors are taking on
more subcontractors to help achieve what
is needed
we have me ask Mayors to change their
focus to ensure that certificates
are compliant on the first appointment
rather than completing the inspection
and then leaving Romanian Works
afterwards unfinished
we are meeting senior managers within
the TLs and Mayors are meeting regularly
to look at new processes and incentives
to make sure the impact of any changes
that we do are are making progress and
we are delivering as many certificates
as possible
so that's compliance in terms of
operational performance
gas call Who deliver our gas servicing
and repairs
remains steady their performance remains
steady their satisfaction score
is improving so we went from 72.2
percent in quarter four to eighty three
percent in quarter one now this isn't as
high as we had hoped but we hope that as
we progress we get more surveys back to
really quantify better statistics around
our resident satisfaction with that
service
Miss we are very pleased with the
performance of Mayors we have seen
continued improvements since the
restructure at during quarter three and
quarter four of last year this has been
seen
excuse me this has been seen with
continuing rise and customer
satisfaction from 90 to 90 just over 95
percent and this is supported by the
post inspections carried out by our
maintenance inspectors who confirm there
is a real increase
um in improvements of service
work is continuing
to reduce the progress on uh progress
order so this is work where we have to
go back where we were unable to complete
the repair in the first instance so we
are progressing to um
to improve that as well as our void
turnaround times
I was talking about our voids so the
void is one of the areas we have put
focus on improving
particularly around the void turnaround
times we are pleased to say it's
improving slowly our performance in this
area is affected by
our kitchen I'm so sorry to interrupt
you for the public the camera is not
picking you up I wonder if you could use
the microphone next next to you please
yes of course thank you
thank you Chad
so let me start with voids we are
um putting a focus on improving this
particularly our void turnaround times
to get our properties re-let as quickly
as possible and the performance around
this has been affected as you may be
aware our kitchen and bathroom
contractor sadly went into
Administration and Mayors did it
challenged
and really pulled aside to help us with
that they completed kitchens and
bathrooms that were left by the
contractor so in doing so they pulled
staff off our void program to complete
that so we didn't have residents left
without kitchen or bathroom facilities
but this will impact us and it will
impact us into Quarter Two as well
um and Mayors will there will be quite a
catch-up that they will need to take to
address the void but uh backlog
uh in terms of the cattle Capital
program spent we are where we are at the
end of quarter one and where we expect
to be with a spend of 22 percent
uh in terms of our income recovery so
our arrears recovery is slow
but it's a a positive trend and although
we are concerned about the future and
what that brings for our residents we
now have a full income team and we are
really feeling the benefits of that we
are able to reach our tenants at a much
sooner
um time scale and assist them with any
arrears before they get to an
unmanageable level and we have changed
the way we
refer those tenants who are struggling
through to our financial well-being team
to get as much support as we possibly
can give them an advice before that debt
builds up
um
we do meet
senior managers within the TLs do meet
um regularly to do what we call monthly
escalated case reviews because we do
find that those residents who are
falling into high rental areas also are
struggling in other areas such as 10
areas around their tenancies or they may
have stopped reporting repairs they want
to go onto the radar so we we look at
those cases historic has
historically and also approach that from
a whole service point of view to try and
find the right way forward for our
resident
and that's it so I I will take any
questions that you have thank you
thank you very much uh casa bayford
thank you chair I would just like to
record my thanks to Michelle for
delivering our report and for
um Sally Sullivan and the team for
compiling it's very very detailed report
it's very comprehensive and it enables
all of us to see
um
how our what is happening without with
amongst our residents and also our
housing stock our successes our huge
successes since um taking things
in-house from his kind of housing but
also the problem problematic areas and
how we're addressing those so thank you
very much to the team
members do you have any questions or
comments counsel us in
it's more of a commented question
actually the first one is to say thank
you very much for the glossary which I
asked for on a previous occasion and
it's so helpful for those of us who
don't work in this field and and just to
remind ourselves about the technical
terms and the other thing I wanted to
say was about void properties I I was
out the other day and I saw of avoid
property with the the metal shutters up
and all of that and work going on in it
and it struck me that I hadn't seen one
for a very very long time and that
actually where I used to live before I
came to fannic you saw them you know all
the time and it really struck me that
it's it's unusual
here now and that's Testament to the to
all the hard work that you're doing and
I'm really impressed with this report
thank you
[Music]
I counselor King first please and then
I'll come to you counseling
thank you
um yeah loads of good work going on so
I'm not knocking that at all but I was
just quite curious about gas call
um and the lack of customer satisfaction
because at the moment there's still 20
of people that are not happy and
previously it was almost one in four so
what's going on there what are people
not happy about and what is being done
about that thank you
so I I don't have the finite detail of
why they're not unhappy I think one of
the issues that we do have is we want
more residents to actually give us
feedback the level of feedback that
we're getting and the engagement is
quite low
um which is probably schooling some of
the satisfaction results and so
there isn't enough data if I'm being
honest to be able to pinpoint a trend as
to it's it's the appointment system or
you know appointments aren't being kept
there's not enough data there to drill
down significantly and be able to give
you a finite as to what what is driving
the dissatisfaction
thank you for explaining that is is
there possibility in the future that
that would be drilled down to look at
the reasons
yes absolutely we are actually look we
are talking with gas call as to how they
can better reach out to residents at the
moment they are using SMS to filter out
their opportunity for residents to give
us feedback and we don't feel that
that's good enough that there needs to
be more channels in which residents can
give us their feedback and we're working
with them at the moment uh as to how we
can logistically do that to get more
feedback from our residents
um on that subject
uh I'd just like to say thank you as
well because we see we see we see on the
ground the positive side of the good
work I.E we get less complaints from
residents so so as a knock-on to us as
well but we def I definitely see more
more going on in in the properties the
properties that we own where I live as
well so I'd just like to say thank you
and also it's it's Testament to your
team that that you don't sugarcoat the
areas that you do need to improve on but
your your evidence in your evidence in
where maybe things are not going as well
as you would like them to go and trying
to look at the reasons why they're not
going well and then trying to move
forward with a with a Target to to
change that and I guess we're all a bit
worried about the future because we
basically don't have enough housing do
we but yeah but thank you
thank you that's very kind thank you
Council Boyd
thank you for your report
um just wanted to touch on
um the resident involvement
um table on
page 33
um where it says about residents
targeted for involvement in Resident
involvement activities and my first
question was
um how are they targeted
and because of the the change in numbers
is it that that first one for quarter
one is like an annual Mass engagement
because there's 3 000 and in the next
quarter there's 18.
um so I just wondered if you could
expand a little bit more on that and
then also
um the drop in sort of I'm probably ties
into it but
um the number of activities and comments
and suggestions so just those kind of
bits please thank you yes of course
thank you so these are calculated on
when we finish projects within the
quarter that's when the statistics fall
into the table so
um the number of consultations carried
out are the number of actual
consultations that we close in that
quarter so it in this instant quarter
one we had one closed
um you'll appreciate that some of our
consultations go on for quite some time
um until they're closed so the number of
residents scrutiny projects that's where
we bring residents in to talk to and for
example in this quarter we had residents
that scrutinized these performance
reports we had residents involved in
um the role of scrutinizing our two
million contractors gas call and mayors
that go along to their meetings and they
ask really poignant questions about the
contract and suggest recommendations and
the number of residents who have
experienced uh expressed in interest
though this is we do from time to time
really push campaigns to push out
opportunities in this quarter we didn't
push a major campaign the the level
which is only one person who's expressed
that's just come through our website
when anybody can express at any time so
that's why that figure is quite low the
reason why you've got quite a high
figure in Rio for the number of
residents Target for involvement
in in involvement activities that's
because that has been linked
um through to our newsletter when we
send out a newsletter we we
we count the number of newsletters that
we sent out in this quarter we sent out
a newsletter to every single tenant and
leaseholder and then we sent additional
newsletters to our high-rise blocks as
well so all residents and that and
that's why we had so many but it might
although we sent the target out in this
court it might be until next quarter
that we get anybody pick anybody up
that's come through that channel and so
that's why that's that high figure
um and then you've got the number of
residents who have been involved in
actual activities with us
um and during that that quarter we would
have picked up some of the residents on
a couple of the and events but the
majority of those are still not they're
still lives they wouldn't have closed
down so quarter one will increase
as we go through the year as we close
our projects down
was there any other action issues that
you wanted me to go through on that
table or have I covered what you
um I guess so it's more
um the terminology of like number of
residents targeted so that suggests that
it's
targeted at a certain group of residents
where is it what you've just said is
it's actually gone to every resident
so I don't know whether it's there
should be a difference in terms of how
you report it that was all
yes I think that's a very valid point
and one that I will take back I think
you're quite correct targeted is not the
right terminology for that so thank you
for that
thank you very much members for your
questions and comments and it just
remains now then for me to thank uh
councilor Jill bayford our cabinet
member for housing and Michelle Jackson
resident involvement manager thank you
for deputizing this evening and
presenting this to us thank you very
much
we move on now then to a gender item
number six a review of our overview and
scrutiny panel work program
for
the rest of this
electoral session I guess for 22.23
do members have any comments they'd like
to make about the work program
I think we've seen tonight if I can just
say that the
cabinet presentations are are becoming
really informative
and normally I guess about 30 to 40
minutes
but this evening was a good hour and it
was very informative and uh perhaps
Council of bayford you could pass on our
thanks to all the cabinet members from
time to time I do thank the leader from
time to time for making a cabinet
available to come and and talk to us and
give us information and give us an
opportunity to question uh the things
that are happening so
um we are happy to note the
work programmers except for Council
fellows yeah thank you chair I did
notice um November we have already got a
Cabinet member presentation I'm not sure
that was I presume it's the leader but
nothing is set for January February or
March so I don't know if we've got any
suggestions
from other people who we'd like to
listen to
members
make contact
with other councilors see if anyone's
got something that they would like us to
get a presentation on
okay
um
could I ask then that they contact you
directly Charles and then you'll share
all that with me yeah okay
thank you very much cancer first it's a
good good point thank you
um our next item then is the forward
plan ex and exempt cabinet report list
uh is there anything from that plan the
panel will wish to consider
if not we are asked to note the report
thank you then and that concludes the
business for tonight's meeting